foreign
well yesterday and I'm this just so we
know I the person's going to stay
Anonymous not even tell Mercy because I
wanted to tell him on the show
yesterday Marsh
somebody very close
to the Dayton hypernova situation
contacted us
on our Facebook page okay and I've
talked to this person
and this person wants to remain
anonymous for for several reasons
suffice to say Mom it's no it's no it's
not it's my sister the person is is very
is close to the family I'll say that
and they said I've been struggling I've
been watching you guys cover
him
for a couple years and I've been
struggling to reach out to you guys but
I'm just gonna tell you so this person
knows him
um this person you know what honestly
dating a hypernova Intel is always
infinitely more interesting than the
videos yeah so oh yeah yeah uh
uh merch uh check your Discord DM so you
have a little more idea who I'm talking
about so you know okay you get it oh
okay perfect so now I'll say this
well Marsha's gonna be mad
oh you're gonna be really mad you're
gonna be mad so I got some new videos
um and I also have this as we know from
Dayton hypernova I found out all the
stuff about the family as we know from
Dayton hyper and over he has been
complaining
over and over again uh about things like
this for example
the bedroom
uh this by the way title is younger
brother and sister husband go upstairs
only time together not to say sorry to
me to get skinhead better that's always
the SE the weird they're having a normal
day and they're not apologizing to me
every five minutes well here you go
[Music]
and he's uh he was upstairs just a
minute ago
um with uh my
brother-in-law my sister's husband and
they're moving a look at his pupils
look at his pupils [ __ ] dinner they
look like [ __ ] tea saucers yeah
big bed out of
the bedroom next to mine or they just it
sounds like you know he has to be
tripping nuts yeah so he's complaining
in this video that the that the the
brother the the excuse me
uh his younger brother and his SI and
his sister was talking about before went
upstairs to to bring down his uh
brother's his brother's bed from his
room to the living room which I'll
explain for a second why [ __ ] pieces
of [ __ ] man right instead of apologizing
to him I [ __ ] dude this is why I'm
I'm siding with him man his family is so
unreasonable I dare that yeah the
brother needs to get a bed the sister's
going up she's helping well Marsh he's
about the max that's why he's
complaining
we're up here several minutes the bed
was the one that was the bed they just
moved out of that room actually
um
these Whispers because they might hear
him
because he's a [ __ ]
and the funniest thing is they know he's
talking I know it's just
my favorite moment of all time is the
brother-in-law being like hey what's up
bro all right and he just ran away
that's spotted they made me they made me
abort abort you know it's like calm down
dude
cue the metal gear alert theme yeah
oh [ __ ] this is physically assaulting me
beating up on the ground and it sounds
like a regular you seem okay and you
have brittle bones and brittle skin and
I feel like if anybody hit you there'd
be evidence now do you want to know
Marsh he's complaining about the bread
getting the bed and not saying sorry to
him do you want to know why they were
bringing the bed downstairs I found this
out through the through the person that
I said
you want to know why they were bringing
the bed downstairs I'm gonna make an
assumption sure
it has something to do with the dad
being a particularly extra sick now the
dad is in such bad shape because of the
cantry can no longer walk upstairs so
they're letting they don't want they
want they want him to be in the house
obviously so they move the brother's bed
who also passed away downstairs so that
his uh so that his dad could be
comfortable in his home I [ __ ] knew
it I guess correct by the way I haven't
seen this boy no he hasn't I told him
nothing on purpose something having to
do with the dad being that because I've
been in that situation before when you
have a relative that's either really
Advanced cancer or something like that
it's like you're moving things around
you're trying to make things I knew Tom
brother already had a room and I knew it
wasn't the little brother's best it's
like yeah that's [ __ ] dad's name is
the dad's name is Jerry by the way
um and yeah his scary hyper nova yeah
Jerry Jerry Jerry paradoxia
uh his dad is uh Jerry Schultz as we
brought up no Jerry hypernova is better
his his dad has advanced cancer and
because of that he did make him
comfortable he's been complaining about
that
um and yelling at everybody and also
um hey Dayton some of you watch these
videos now Dayton
um I remember when you said that you
were kicked out of the place and when
you were kicked out of place to threw
your [ __ ] on the lawn that never
happened you lied about that
um and I also know that I'll continue
with this video here's something that
you probably wouldn't have normally seen
he is here you go
uh he actually went out to a bar
and he filmed and this is the title
large transphobic men violently harassed
me outside of a bar
[Music]
do those guys look at them they don't
look like they're harassing anybody and
also
like pick imagine that's us right yeah
by the way I call dibs I'm the fat guy
in the sweatsuit that's a good spot hold
on can I say that is a sweet sweatsuit
I'm very jealous of you
um yeah and he looks like a fat Prince
Harry
um
he's the one annoying them right like if
that were us he's filming them if
someone's trying to show me squirrely
weirdo is just filming us through the
front door of a place the glass I mean
I'm not saying I'd beat him up getting
his face but I'd probably turn to him
and go can I can we help you
what's up what's up bud can we help you
with something like and that to Dayton
right away is God they're harassing
they're transphobic no you're [ __ ]
weird everywhere you go you're
off-putting everywhere you go it has
nothing to do with the fact that you
wear dresses and you like to suck dicks
or whatever absolutely
harassing me physically they're like
he's hammered listen to how drunk he is
oh wow cause he speaks up when he's
because he's at a bar listen listen okay
all right there's three dudes out there
harassing me physically they're like
physically not only the slurring but
he's got more
like gusto in his voice yeah you know he
doesn't ever talk like that like he's
like really like loud and talking [ __ ]
[ __ ] crazy Timmy that's Timmy that's
Timmy that was Timmy
that's Timmy apparently
I'm just drunk like stop
sorry but I understand but we're trying
to Defuse The Situation just three
people harassing me did you guys start
with them is that what it sounds like it
sounds like you guys started with them
huh
[Music]
here's the other thing until that you
learn the entire Community knows him
that little bar area knows him they
despise him
the [ __ ] despise him
um and uh and the thing is is he
probably got the reactions he wanted the
first few times when he was younger
right like they're harassing a trans
person and it works yeah and then after
a while it's like boy who cried wolf
[ __ ] it's like how many times do you get
harassed before maybe you're the common
denominator here I could also tell you
with absolute certainty that Sherman has
never hit him
ever
at all not once
that's uh that's another guaranteed he
just just completely lying about that
too everything he says is a [ __ ] lie
um let me see here uh I have a little
bit more here uh here
they just moved the bed from there
downstairs I think they're putting I I
don't know exactly but I think what
they're probably doing is moving into
the dining room so that uh uh I also
find out and I quote he has people that
will tolerate him in public ask for
actual friendships not really
my dad well yeah that's clear from he's
from what we know of observing this is
something else that I didn't know he
didn't used to be like this he used to
be normal
until
his ex his ex he had a girlfriend
ex-girlfriend left him and apparently
his ex-girlfriend was hot
like for real hot like not a joke wow so
when and then of course after she left
him he went on to claim to everybody
that she was also abusive of him
but he only
believing that she was abusive when she
got married
good for her that she got away from him
and married somebody that was worth
marriage yeah of course absolutely but
so everything after that I apparently
something broke in him at some point
I don't know if it was drugs I don't
know what it was but look at those eyes
those eyes are not the eyes of like
somebody that's not on drugs
now those are the eyes of a sick dude
you know and it's like weird right
because I try to have empathy for
everybody but when this guy's got nobody
left to support him and he's out in the
streets I'm looking forward to those
days
this is this
bro so so move that that being said
before we continue this
I asked for them to make a GoFundMe
for his dad
the family is now being talked about
making GoFundMe sounds like a promoted
here obviously right
um to help them out to help them out
yeah exactly but the the thing that was
made very clear in that is like I need
to know the only person that would have
access to this will be his mother
his father or his sister that's oh no no
no we'd have to do it I guess the mother
or the sister obviously the father can't
be sorry the mother of the sister
correct well they can't be bothered with
this right right so the mother of the
sister said yeah you set it up so yeah
you set it up but you make them the
clear beneficiary and then you don't
ever touch the money that's easy
but yeah obviously we're not going to
give oh Earl here the money so that for
two reasons number one because I think
that those parents are some of the most
patient and nicest people you could ever
[ __ ] ask for
but number two the important reason
Royce is that I want to make sure that
he can't get a [ __ ] penny and that he
knows that he can't get a dollar that he
knows that he can't get a dollar and his
[ __ ] his little money Train's about
to [ __ ] end you're a piece of [ __ ]
Dean and the more and by the way by the
way we have a skull a call schedule
we're about to find out a lot more about
you Dayton this is just the very
beginning yeah but I want to let you
know that those [ __ ] days are over
you're done preying on this family
you're done and the more you find out
about him piece of [ __ ] all he does is
lie all he he doesn't even see his
father
like he's in the house you'd have to
you'd have to figure at this point it's
like bro he's on his way out you should
be even if you hate your dad yeah it
should be a time to kind of turn things
around you know of course absolutely 100
percent
he's staying in the recliner chair
downstairs recovering listen from colon
cancer that he recently uh went to the
hospital for surgery about anyway
they're moving the bed anyway did you
hear the most important part of this
conversation face he makes the day
anyway
look look that he recently went to the
hospital for surgery about anyway there
bed and stuff
[Music]
Nazi skinhead radio show internet show
Nazi skinhead making money and my dad
money not me money I work hard I watch
that's gonna be the beauty of it good
when he finds out I can't wait complains
good
when he complains he's not getting a
taste tell Dayton I want him to know it
was us
foreign
they didn't make no efforts and nor
should they because they're [ __ ] at
this point but it's just I'm keeping on
right for the fact that these people
Gaslight everything about what happened
to me the physical we know what happened
to you now
we know you're a liar
because I repeatedly happened to me and
we just now have the receipts every time
I was wearing women's fashion anytime I
was wearing a dress around that skin and
by the way that's the thing the other
thing I found out
nobody has ever criticized him for the
way he dresses for the way he looks even
his family even his brother who he says
that doesn't happen he all just uses an
excuse because he's so hateable and he's
so unaware that it's because he's a
piece of [ __ ] he's so hateable that he
missed about that the trans thing yeah
it has to be that
that it was over twice my size I was
getting beat for it
over and over and over again look he
didn't but I kind of wish he did
he was beating me sometimes when I
wasn't and I was just talking back while
he was insulting me as a trump supporter
he was insanely so basically he was
minding his own business talking to his
dad about Trump because the family
pretty much is kind of you know right
wing and you [ __ ] stuck your nose in
and started [ __ ] starting a little
[ __ ] for no reason right that was you
right that's you're the guy because
you're innocent you [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] and all by the way all the all the
we were correct about this assumption
all the [ __ ] uh the Special Care cops
I don't know what they're called they're
different in every town but you know the
ones that deal with the Cuckoos know him
very well
right I don't know if Goku's is the
[ __ ] right medical term it is that's
actually what I would have used yeah
that's a medical term yeah
Trump supporter
and he was beating me for speaking back
and he was beating me for wearing
dresses weirdly videotape everything and
you never caught any never caught that
people ignored all of it I've reached
out you're so pilled out you're so
[ __ ] pilled out you [ __ ] you junky
piece of [ __ ] just finished the bottle
yeah [ __ ] seriously be brave
people for once in your life do
something that will benefit the entire
town of Dayton Ohio they don't have a
lot to be happy for they're Dayton Ohio
they ignored it
and they insulted me
they insulted me forever
being on the wrong side
of a skinhead's behavior
your father is dying the mother the
mother was only one making money did you
know there's something else I found out
well obviously the mother's the only one
earning not anymore she had to retire to
take care of the dad
that's why the another reason the
GoFundMe isn't I want that yeah she had
to retire early from work to take care
of the dead because he's in that bad
shape and because you know their [ __ ]
son can't step up and help no no he no
he can't he could step up and go to the
bar
but yet that's my point but it's okay I
guess I'll retire early because the guy
who lives here for free I can't even do
laundry
and to think about this the last car
trip he took with his dad it wasn't for
them to go to a game or something it was
because he whined for him to take him
like three Towns over to see Nicole
Richie at a Comic-Con
Christina Ricci sorry Christina Ricci at
a Comic-Con
versus always thinking of a hotter one
yeah skin hits Behavior to be for not
staying on the right side of it hey
buddy he's long since dead
he's been dead for years now normal
people can put [ __ ] behind him once
people are dead
saying on good terms calling him dating
a hero Nova it's a man who was beating
the [ __ ] on me in my own home
they never saved me through any of it
and my cat isn't over here so
that's not your cat
and your wishes
eating so anyway
I keep my cat away from these people too
you're grinding your teeth what do you
want
you're grinding your teeth what do you
want
I think he takes [ __ ] benzos but
Adderall too like I think yeah he's
doing the mix that poor man speedball
yeah they're negligent people to the cat
it's disgusting Behavior
the skin has been gone two years so
it's obviously not as absolutely
terrible around here but it's absolutely
disgusting that never once these people
have empathy in a situation where a
person was getting beat you have no
empathy that your dad's dying of cancer
you pee I'm sorry go ahead no it's just
because um your brother and your sister
right now are carrying your dead
brother's bed down into stairs putting
it in a living room which is a massive
inconvenience for everybody in the house
because they all have empathy for you
the dying patriarching your family
what are you talking about I hate this
[ __ ] guy I love this for years we've
watched him cry about nobody having
empathy while he never thinks of anyone
else
I mean my sister and my brother-in-law
drove me to the emergency room
themselves after one of the beans were
so bad that a bone was broken in my body
from the beating
and instead of x-rays medical records
there's nobody did it happen there's no
proof there's never any proof you know
well that seems to be a lie any empathy
to me from a beating of by a man over
twice my son they didn't take you to the
[ __ ] hospital they take you to a
[ __ ] fire station so they could drop
you off like an orphan but they said you
were way too old
I think at that time he was three times
My Size because he was so large he was
obese
um instead of actually expressing
empathy to me
they said it takes what a flaky face
[ __ ] too look at the flakes it's
on his skin you could see it
two to tango
it takes two to Tingo
yeah that's exactly what they said
I remember going off on them
I mean I cannot believe these people I
mean that was yeah you don't instigate
anything you're just a nice nice guy
Dayton who steals credit cards steals
credit cards buys stuff without telling
them doesn't gets mad if your dad gets
the wrong Pizza go [ __ ] yourself Dayton
It's Beginning
and they seem to act a little bit more
corrected you hear about that
but then the beatings kept happening and
their behavior got worse yeah well
Dayton the beatings is gonna happen till
[ __ ] morale improves how does that
sound all right if I could bring back
your brother like some kind of
Frankenstein monster to beat you again I
would and then I'd give him the hand
Jax's arms from Mortal Kombat
piece of [ __ ] I [ __ ] hate this guy
it's awesome